just before we get started some of you
might know that i have another channel
called mega projects which is all about
mega projects if you don't please do
subscribe to it
well by popular demand i wanted to cover
some things on that channel that weren't
quite
mega enough for it so i present to you a
brand new channel
side projects covering secret soviet
space weapons
world war ii's greatest airplanes
history's lost treasures and
a whole lot more new videos three times
a week on that channel so if you're
thinking simon doesn't make enough
videos for me
well problem solved link below and let's
get into it
[Music]
today we take a look at a pirate unlike
any other steed bonnet
the gentleman pirate so called because
he came from a life of luxury
and leisure he was wealthy he was well
educated he was influential in high
society and yet
he left that life behind and instead
decided to become a pirate
his motivation whatever it was already
makes him unique
among the pirates we've covered on this
channel but another original aspect of
bonnet was that he was completely
ill-prepared for life as a pirate
captain he didn't know how to sail
he didn't know how to navigate and he
didn't know how to fight but that did
not deter him
in the slightest although it did cause
some slight friction with his men
this almost makes him a sort of comical
character especially when compared to
his peers but
to everyone's surprise he wasn't the
most terrible pirate in the world he
took his fair share of prizes and
secured long lasting notoriety for
himself thanks
mainly to his association with
blackbeard in the end though
steed bonnet proved to be a tragic
figure as the rest of the world was not
impressed or amused by his antics and
ultimately he shared the same
harsh fate as most of his confederates
[Music]
steve bonnett was born in 1688 on the
island of barbados
he came from a wealthy family as his
parents had a large plantation a couple
of miles from the bombadian capital of
bridgetown and
he inherited it all once his parents
died he received a good education and
was brought up to be
a proper and upstanding member of
society as a young adult
bonnet married a woman named mary
allenby in 1709 and together they had
four children
through the years he saw his standing in
society steadily improve
his wife was also the daughter of a
wealthy planter so he got a large
dowry by marrying her and his own
plantation seemed to thrive
he joined the british army and served in
the local militia where he attained the
rank of major in other words
steed bonnet seemingly had everything
that a man of the era
could ever want and yet he did something
strange in 1717
something that puzzled his
contemporaries and still puzzles
historians to this day
he gave up his life and decided he
wanted to become a pirate
what exactly prompted bonnet to do this
remains a mystery the main motives why
men turn to piracy in those days was
because they didn't know how to make
money any other way
or because they wanted to escape the
oppression of their governments or
because
they were forced into it none of the
above applied to steed bonnet
he was considered a gentleman of leisure
and wealth who had the money the
influence and the status to
live out all his years in comfort but
for some reason this did not appeal to
him
instead he preferred to risk his life on
the high seas
so why did he do it both his
contemporaries and modern historians
have offered their opinions
some simply believe that he was bored
and wanted a bit of excitement in his
life
if this is true then steve bonnett
should definitely be in contention for
the most extreme
midlife crisis in history others thought
that he suffered from some kind of
mental illness while
charles johnson in his seminal account a
general history of pirates
claimed that bonnet wanted to leave his
old life behind
due to some discomforts he found in a
married state
implying that steed bonnet was doing all
of this just to get away from his wife
there is also a possibility that his
financial situation may not have been as
comfortable as we previously suggested
as there is a record of him borrowing 1
700 pounds at the start of the year
maybe a poor harvesting season left him
in dire straits and
bonnets thought he had no alternative
but to turn to piracy or maybe he had
already made up his mind and
knew that he'd never have to pay the
loan back ultimately all of these
hypotheses remain
guesswork since bonnet himself never
gave an explicit reason
speaking of charles johnson we often
start off these pirate bios specifying
that
he is the main source and also that he's
not particularly reliable so
everything has to be taken with a grain
of salt well that is not necessarily
true in this case because although a
general history of pirates remains an
important source
we actually have a more trustworthy
secondary one because steed bonnet was
arrested and tried for piracy
a detailed account of his trial in south
carolina was published and survives to
this day
so we have corroboration of the things
he did as a pirate
[Music]
like we said in 1717 steed bonnet left
his life behind to became a pirate
unlike every other pirate captain bonnet
did not steal his ship he purchased it
it was a sloop which he named the
revenge and had it fitted with 10
cannons he also hired his crew around 70
to 80 men who received a monthly salary
paid out of bonnet's own pocket instead
of simply awarding them a share of the
plunder this was probably done
more out of necessity seeing as how a
pirate crew could depose their captain
for being incompetent and then
vote on somebody else to take his place
this was probably the only way that
bonnet could have maintained his
captaincy given that he knew almost
nothing when it came to sailing
navigation
or maritime warfare once bonnet had his
ship ready and his crew assembled he
needed to wait for the right opportunity
the revenge stayed quietly in the
harbour for a few days and
everyone who inquired was simply told
that bonnet purchased it to start
trading with the nearby islands
then one night without word to his
family or friends the captain
abandoned his life of leisure and set
sail on the high seas
headed for the eastern coast of north
america you might think this
haphazard approach to piracy would be a
recipe for disaster but steed bonnet was
surprisingly successful he took his
first prizes off the coast of the colony
of virginia where he plundered not one
not two but four ships
in a short amount of time the anne the
turbot the young
and the endeavor two of them sailed out
of scotland and one out of england and
those were free to go after being
plundered the turbid however was
set to sail from barbados and bonnet
insisted on having it confiscated and
burned down
he would go on to repeat this with other
ships from his native island we're not
sure if he did this to try and prevent
the word of his actions from reaching
back home or if he harbored some kind of
resentment for barbados anyway after
virginia bonnet headed for new york
where he captured another sloop and then
resupplied his ship according to his
trial documents by august 1717
the revenge was already heading back
south to the coast of south carolina
when he captured two more ships first
was a sloop from barbados carrying
sugar run and slaves and captained by a
man named joseph palmer and the second
was a brigantine from
new england under captain thomas porter
again bonnet burned down the ship from
barbados
this initial run proved to be quite
successful although realistically this
was more due to the skill and expertise
of the crew rather than bonnet himself
by this point most of the pirates
probably figured out that their captain
was a complete
rookie when it came to all seafaring
matters and some discontent had already
started
brewing it was decided that they would
make land for a while and
go somewhere where they could actually
spend some of their ill-gotten gains
the revenge set sail for nassau in the
bahamas which was a pirate haven at that
time
there steed bonnet made the acquaintance
of numerous other sea dogs such as
himself and
among them was captain edward teach
better known as the
infamous blackbeard
[Music]
right off the bat we should mention that
from this point on the careers of
blackbeard and bonnet intertwined for a
little while we've already done a video
on blackbeard so
if you'd like to get more of the story
from that perspective why not give
a little look-see to that video anyway
blackbeard was a skilled and experienced
captain not to mention that he was
respected
and feared by his crewman he was the
antithesis of steed bonnet and yet
somehow
the two struck up a relationship and
decided to sail together for a while
many would say that blackbeard was
simply using bonnet to strengthen his
own fleet and they would
probably be right this was before edward
teach had gotten his hands on the queen
anne's revenge his
main flagship for most of his practical
career having bonnet's revenge on his
side would have been a significant
advantage
this worked out well for the captain
from barbados though at least at first
as
having someone like blackbeard in charge
probably quelled any desire to leave or
revolt that
might have been developing among
bonnet's crew so the fleet left nassau
with steed bonnet officially a guest
aboard blackbeard's ship while
a lieutenant richards had been given
temporary command of the revenge
they proved to be a formidable force in
the waters surrounding the bahamas and
took at least a dozen prizes on their
way to the east coast of america
again going by court records by the time
they reached north carolina they had
four ships in their fleet and between
300 to 400 fighting men you might think
this would be a good thing for steed
bonnet as
he set out to be a pirate captain not
actually knowing anything about what
that entailed
and was now part of one of the most
powerful and feared convoys in american
waters
however that was not the case in fact
bono was quite depressed as he realized
what he truly was a prisoner who
willingly gave up command of his ship
to his own captor sure on the surface
his relationship with teach was still
cordial and
he wasn't deprived of his share of the
plunder but bonnet understood
that this would only continue as long as
he played the role of the content
guest any attempt to reclaim his
authority over the revenge would have
likely put an end to all niceties and
worst of all bonnet would have probably
discovered that most of his men
preferred to sail under blackbeard
anyway
in private bonner confessed to some of
the men who were loyal to him that he
felt tired and
shameful for his actions and if possible
he would have gladly left the pirate
life behind and
started somewhere fresh in spain or
portugal as he could not bear to face a
fellow englishman
alas it seemed the only way he would
regain command of his ship was if
blackbeard decided to surrender it
according to certain versions of the
story this is exactly what happened
they say that once blackbeard captured
le concorde which he renamed to the
queen anne's revenge
he had no more need for bonnet's ship
and let him go independent again once
this happened bonnet immediately forgot
any plans about giving up the pirate
life and assumed command of the revenge
again
however his newfound autonomy did not
last long his inexperience once again
caused problems with the crew after an
ill-fated attempt to plunder a
well-armed merchantman named the
protestant caesar in the waters of
honduras in the spring of 1718.
not only did he fail but bonnet was
injured in the skirmish leaving him
unfit for duty soon afterwards he
ran into blackbeard's fleet again and
his own men pleaded with the other
captain to assume command
of the revenge once more which he did
bonnet once again found himself
blackbeard's guest prisoner some
accounts like that of charles johnson
make no mention of this brief period of
independence so
whether or not it happened is actually a
matter of some debate
we do now however when blackbeard and
bonnet severed their ties completely and
that's just a few months later
in may 1718 blackbeard used his fleet to
blockade the port city of charlestown
south carolina or charleston as we call
it today
afterwards the ships traveled to topsail
island off the coast of north carolina
which was used as a popular resting and
hiding spot for pirates there the queen
anne's revenge ran aground and became
unsalvageable
as did one of the smallest loops in the
fleet with two ships lost blackbeard
decided that it might be a good idea to
get a pardon from the governor of north
carolina
a man named charles eden all pirates
were free to do this
in an effort to make the waters of the
atlantic saver king george the first of
britain
issued a proclamation for suppressing
pirates in the west indies which became
known
as the king's pardon of 1718. basically
it was a one-time offer
available to any pirate no matter how
heinous their criminal activities were
as long as they applied before the
deadline not only would their slate be
wiped clean but they could also receive
a commission to become a pirate hunter
and take down their former confederates
who did not accept the king's pardon
backbeard and bonnet traveled to the
city of bath and obtained pardons for
them and their crews from governor eden
blackbeard and his men then left on
their way but bonnet stayed behind for a
while hoping to get permission to become
a privateer during the time that he had
been a pirate england went to war
against spain so
he thought that he could basically
continue where he left off and be on the
right side of the law by only
targeting spanish merchants eventually
bonnet was told that he could go to the
island of saint thomas from
where he could obtain a privateer's
commission when he finally returned to
his ship
bonnet discovered one last treachery
from blackbeard the other pirate captain
had stripped the revenge of all supplies
loot and useful materials
placed them aboard the other remaining
sloop and took off many scholars
now believe that this had been his plan
all along and that he intentionally
wrecked the queen anne's revenge to have
an excuse to
disband his large crew as for steve
bonnet he might have been stranded on
topsail island but at least he was in
command of the revenge again furthermore
his crew
hated blackbeard now so it was decided
once the ship was repaired and seaworthy
again
they would go in pursuit of the one who
had betrayed them once they set off they
soon noticed a group of 20 or so men
marooned on a nearby sandbar
bonnet rescued them and discovered that
they were part of blackbeard's crew left
behind because
blackbeard had too many hands on deck
for just one ship as you might imagine
they
also wanted revenge against their former
captain and they were glad to join
bonnet's ranks
bonnet was still much more inexperienced
in matters of warfare than blackbeard
but he had
the bigger ship the bigger crew and his
men were highly motivated by their
desire for vengeance
it would have been an interesting part
of pirate history and a fitting end to
their chapter if the two
met up again and engaged in one final
battle unfortunately
this never happened bonnet had heard
words that blackbeard had moored his
ship in an estuary called ocracoke inlet
but by the time he got there he found it
empty and he never again
encountered the treacherous blackbeard
with revenge no longer an option bonnet
wanted to return to his previous plan
traveled to saint thomas and
receive a letter of mark to become a
privateer against spain however
there was a problem because blackbeard
had stolen all of their supplies they
needed water
food and liquor but that posed another
problem they couldn't just plunder a
ship
technically they weren't pirates anymore
as they had accepted the king's pardon
this was a one-time deal and if they
broke it now there would be
no turning back they couldn't buy
anything either because blackbeard had
also made off with their treasure
in the end they encountered a merchant
ship full of goods and forced it to
trade with them they made off with
barrels full of pork and bread and
instead left behind a few casks of rice
and an old cable which
was the chain holding the anchor they
were probably hoping to get away with it
on a technicality since they committed
an act of trade not piracy
even though it had been basically forced
at gunpoint and
heavily one-sided they still didn't have
any liquor though and for pirates they
might as well not have had any air to
breathe this is why a couple of days
later they
plundered i i mean traded with another
ship which provided them with two
hogsheads of rum and
two of molasses it is uncertain what
bonnet plans to give them an exchange
because
the other ship took advantage of an
opportunity and fled before the
transaction was completed
after this all pretenses were dropped
and they became full-fledged pirates
again
pardon be damned as a precaution though
bonnet did change his name to captain
thomas and the name of his ship
to the royal james hoping that maybe
this might conceal his identity body
spent a short time as captain thomas but
it was his most successful time
clearly he was no longer the same
inexperienced naive man that he was when
he started
he was more respected even feared some
historians claim that steve bonnett was
one of the few
real pirates to actually make prisoners
walk the plank as
this was a practice mostly popularized
by the book treasure island by
robert louis stevenson bonnet prowled
the waters of the carolinas traveling up
north into virginia and delaware
capturing almost a dozen ships of which
two he kept and
added to his fleet
[Music]
after a few profitable months at sea
bonnet needed a place to make
land and careen his ship for repairs he
chose the estuary of cape fear river in
north carolina hurricane season was
approaching so
this was intended to be quite a long
stay unfortunately for bonnet
these last few successful months had
also increased his profile significantly
charles eden the governor of north
carolina might have been somewhat
indifferent to pirate activity
but his neighboring counterparts were
not as amenable the governors
of the colonies knew that they had
dangerous pirates in their waters and
wanted them dealt with
consequently the governor of south
carolina robert johnson ordered a man
named colonel william rhett
to arm two pirate hunters and set sail
to rid the colony of any pirates
the same thing happened with the
governor of virginia who sent out his
own men
to take down blackbeard as far as rhett
is concerned we're not sure if he
specifically targeted steed bonnet or if
he intended to attack any pirate he
encountered some have said that he
simply stumbled upon bonnet's fleet
while
looking for charles vane another
infamous pirate that you'll likely see
on this channel someday either way ret
set out in september 1718 in two sloops
the henry
and the sea nymph and soon received word
of several pirate ships anchored
at cape fear river colonel rhett reached
bonnet's location on the night of
september the 26th the fight commenced
the next morning as
bonnet wanted to sail past the pirate
hunters and head for the ocean
however the river was not wide enough
and during the chaos both of rhett's
ships as well as the royal james were
grounded in shallow water after hours of
fighting the south carolina started to
gain the upper hand
at one point towards the end bonnet
allegedly wanted to
blow up his ship rather than be captured
but he was stopped by his men who
decided to surrender ultimately steed
bonnet and 33 of his men survived the
battle were arrested
and taken to charlestown as a gentleman
bonnet was given preferential treatment
and was
allowed to stay in the house of the
provost marshal on october 24th he
actually managed to escape but was
only at large for four days before being
captured again his men
didn't have it so good after 33 29 were
found guilty of piracy and sentenced to
death and
they were all hanged on november the 8th
a few days later bonnet's trial took
place and
he too was found guilty and sentenced to
die his date of execution
was scheduled for december the 10th so
bonnet still had some
time to try and evade his ghastly fate
he begged
he argued he pleaded he tried blaming
blackbeard he
wrote letters to anyone who would listen
attempt to get his sentence commuted
he managed to gain a lot of public
sympathy and even his captor colonel
rhett
was moved to the point that he offered
to travel with bonnet to england for a
new trial the gentleman pirate
used his pleas and his tears to move
everyone
except for the one person who mattered
governor johnson
despite public pressure the governor
remained steadfast in his decision
arguing that bonnet had already broken
his word once so on december 10th an
almost insensible steed bonnet was
dragged to the gallows and in front of a
crowd that exhibited more pity
than contempt or hatred he was hanged
nowadays a historical marker is
all that remains of the spot where the
notorious gentleman pirate and
29 of his men met their end so i really
hope you found that video interesting if
you did please do hit that thumbs up
button below also do subscribe
also check out my new channel side
projects linked to below
and thank you for watching